uh does anyone want to give their
opinion on the ball to uv
yeah i don't like dv6's door handles
this is so this is welcome to kama's
electric car fleet as you can see
all the cars and at comma are electric i
don't even know whose camry that is over
there and that's our oh it's a hybrid
and that's definitely not our rav4 nope
nope just okay every blue car comma has
is electric
uh well i can't see it every blue car in
this shot is electric
we care about the environment guys
uh no look i spent 40 grand on this
thing so
please i need at least like
[Music]
40 people to buy comma 3s for their bult
um and if you do that i'll keep buying
cars otherwise i won't
um yeah we need we need 40 people to buy
uh we'll get 40 volt users
yeah i mean if we have one percent of
the chevy volts by the way if you're
gonna buy a bolt uh maki next year we're
done buying cars this year the only car
we'll buy this year is a toyota security
car if you vote
no ford
only chevy
this this continues look it has it has
two kinds of plugs
oh yes it came with a charger the ev6 by
the way
oh that bump is part of it
oh yeah alex doesn't like this
it's so weird
yeah
nick's upstairs building a harness
i said maki next year but then no fords
yeah and maki next year maybe i don't
know i'm not excited about it
this is this is
kama's whole fleet of electric cars we
have here a kia ev6 yeah blue's cruise
is so terrible
uh oh by the way if you're about what
yeah oh is it
yeah okay the install here is just a
camera just like the normal
cars um
yeah yeah was the install terrible on
the ford we rented two or is that fun
oh that was camera installed all right
cool yeah once like a mainstream ford
has camera installed what we'll chew
forward but
what's in the back there does it come
with a tire
wait it doesn't come with a tire
wait really did we get stiff to tire
almost all cars have gone without tires
what do they come with instead oh
they're just run flasks
and i probably have like a small
compressor somewhere
no they don't come with tires anymore
yeah
do do any of these come with spare tires
i don't know this is what some guys
saying rubber is not eco-friendly
um yeah i mean these wheels don't look
bad actually look at the wheel that
looks pretty good yeah
yeah
oh i got stuff on my hand
i regret that
wait a rivie guys a rivien comes with a
spare tire if i spend like 130 thousand
dollars on iridium
does the rivian come with a charger
because the ev6 does not the bulk comes
with the charger let's see if it's any
good
i can't believe that
i know
all right
looks okay
all right any questions about our
commitment to electric vehicles
this is a greener more green comma
where we commit to electric vehicles
like this bolt euv
this cost me forty thousand dollars
that's how serious i am about a
commitment i even paid some stupid deal
or up charge
and by me i mean alex did it all
make climate change chill
bro no no we're here to save you from
the climate crisis
uh if you buy a common three in a bolt
um oh yes no no real talk though don't
buy the supercruise one
okay so this car
gm had this problem and it had it in the
vault too called the ascm ascm stands
for ass shitty control module and the
supercruise ones have two of them
uh the volt has one of them the bolt euv
premier edition has zero ascms
uh which means that you don't have to
deal with anything in the back of the
car when you install it all you have to
do is uh
is uh you know just up here it's really
easy to install just like all the other
camera only cars
we're gonna make the port good
that's it
that's it does anyone have anything
to ask about the bolt
do we have any bolt users watching your
bolts about to get good shane promised
me it's going to be good
oh it's going to get end to end long oh
yeah
no we think that antenna long is long's
gonna be a lot better on the evs cause
they can like accelerate and decelerate
quickly
did we break any clips yet
he's glued
can you buy the bolt off me no no no no
we're going to keep it we're we're
committed to electric vehicles
we take climate change very seriously
we we care about causes
did it break
great it's easy all right cool that was
easy
15k for fsd is a scam i don't know fsd
looks pretty cool
how many guys did it take to install a
comma everyone's just excited about the
new car
uh no really it takes like it takes like
30 minutes if you're new to it
um we can do it faster we don't have any
bolt harnesses in stock nick's upstairs
building one
um i think that's it just a quick stream
uh
this is our bolt euv
if you're buying a bolt you want to buy
the bolt euv premier you do not want to
buy the supercruise edition we
absolutely will wait 48 hours for the
mount to cure
is it 22
yeah
oh really so not all the premiers have
it
i don't know maybe there's just an
addition there's an addition okay okay
um yeah we put it in the it's in the
compatibility flow don't buy the super
cruise one it probably won't ever be
supported
uh sorry super cruise
like you know what it's gonna be a joke
on the bolt forms in a year
everyone's gonna be saying yo uh
i can't believe you bought shitty super
cruise when i'm
driving around with my open pilot and
it's way better what's wrong with super
cruise it's just like look super cruise
was good in 2017.
you can watch my videos from back in the
day it's all archived i loved my
cadillac with super cruise but open
pilot today is just leaps and bounds
better super cruise has not gotten
better openpilot has ota updated so many
times
it's so good now compared to
really every other system except maybe
for autopilot
fsd is better at the high end features
but everyone's even saying it and when
we ship end to end long it's going to be
hands down about to the best
um
yeah
1.0 when
uh
we're hoping for 0.9 by the end of the
year
one zero point nine coming
on zero
yeah zero zero eight zero eight was a
long series that's how long it took us
to get lane list to be good enough that
we ship it by default
uh and zero nine is going to be the end
to end long and 1.0 is going to be 100
end to end it's not going to use a radar
it's going to have navigate on open
pilot 1.0 is going to have everything 09
might even get some beta navigate an
open pilot we've started to work on it
oh by the way by the way also go and
come a pencil we need 150 more dcam
images you can see the improvement from
50 to 100 but we need 250 and then we
can give you guys lane change without uh
needing
if you have a car with a blind spot
monitor and you have a comma three uh
you won't need to
you can do zero comp lane changes
uh on a fish load pilot
i know some forks already have this
you know again you're not checking your
blind spot we can actually make it check
the blind spot with a combination of a
blind spot monitor and uh the comma
three
and that should be enough to do a full
self driving
uh how many sales of common body i don't
know i saw like 60 of them or something
uh pretty good
all right that was 10 minutes
thanks guys
bolt get your bolt it's going to be
pretty good if you're thinking about an
electric car consider a bolt euv we do
support nissans they're a little bit
annoying to install
um we're gonna we have a ford now we're
gonna upstream but yeah nissan ford
mazda are all i hear the mazda port's
pretty good but um yeah if you want to
buy a car buy one that we have we should
include maybe what our full list of cars
is and how much we like them i think
that actually be cool for the website
maybe we'll do that
all right cool
thanks guys